left-hander madison bumgarner he's won
his last two starts including what we're
gonna call a seven inning no hitter
sunday in atlanta
and this ball is toward left center
field and it's gonna drop down story is
digging hard towards second and trevor
now will uh
get there easily as david peralta had
some issues with it it'll be a straight
up double
so a two-out opportunity for the rockies
give cj crone an opportunity
and this ball pulled to left base hit
story cuts the bag he'll score easily
a double and a single with two outs and
the rockies lead one nothing that'll
boil cj crow
at 182 opponents batting average against
that's good for 10th
best in the national league just a
second road start this year
did he go yes he did
one two three got him on a back foot
slider
paved smith gone strikeout number one
for gray
one two great pitch at 96. you could
tell
out of the gate john feels like his arms
fresh he's got the good heater tonight
and he also has a little extra bounce on
the mound once he strikes you out
is it kind of like i got you
right-handed hitting first baseman
cj crone 3-2 pitch runner going swinging
a miss strike him out
two in the end he might have been ball
four krone body helped him out
bumgarner will take it it is madison
bumgarn to lead it off here
madison's gotta base it into left field
and that's the first diamondbacks hit
tonight madison bumgarner
as dribble walked his first plate
appearance
[Applause]
that's a fair ball then meters on the
run
and he's headed for third tony paris
chica sending it in
here's the throw he's in there and we're
tied
as dribble cabrera it's a 1-1 ball game
that bounced just
fair down that first base line david
peralta now
david peralta into right center here
comes cabrera
the throw was cut off and it's 2-1
diamondbacks boy
peralta is at it again
great a little rattled here trying to
get out of this third escobar now headed
to a double play his first time up
two runs are in peralta's at second and
kelly's at first
[Applause]
and warlow knocks it into the gap here
comes the freight train
three to one diamondbacks
four consecutive two out hits
now that guy meant they hit him i tell
you what it'd do a lot
for the diamondbacks and also for nick
if he could get a big hit here here's
the pitch
ahmed swings this one down to third and
the throw to first into the dirt and not
caught a runch scores a bouncer
from puente's the third baseman crowe
tried to short hop it it popped out of
his glove
and ahmed beat the pick out of the year
by krone to the bag
scoring from third base kelly to get the
divebacks another run it's four in the
inning
4-1 d-backs and another colorado air
here's carrera now
trying to hit it where they ain't and he
rolls it into right center
5-1 diamondbacks another rbi for his
drooble
somehow that snuck through there and
another two-out rbi hit for the
diamondbacks
smothered it into the ground there but
hit it in a good spot no
rocky defender can get there peyton
swift comes out
john gray leads off the fifth against
madison bumgarner
madison now finding that rhythm that
randy johnson was speaking about
madison had an 11-pitch fourth and now
strikes down greater starts at fifth
one and two on garrett hampson ryan
mcmahon on deck
right there with a cutter strikeout
number five for mad bum
got him madison bumgardner strikes out
the side in the fifth
he's punched out six and leads it five
to one
tapio will face young left on left one
out and the diamond backs up five to one
and this is served to left it's going to
get down for a base hit
fuente's around third josh will come
home with the second run
5-2 pin single and a ribby for rymel
tapia charlie blackman over three
blackman shoots it out to left center
peralta backing up
and he runs it down a one two three for
alex young
d-backs lead the rockies 5-2
eskimo is going to lead it off gerardo
escobar
escobar has got a hit tonight a run band
and he's one for three
off the middle and that one trickles
into center it's a hit for escobar his
second base hit tonight
josh rojas oh for three dalton varsio in
the on deck circle he
drills it deep to left center field josh
rojas
has done it again
rojas homers in back-to-back games
and make it 7-2 diamondbacks
how that's a nice adjustment right there
the first pitch of the at-bat he was so
tardy he hit it over into his own dugout
made the adjustment got the barrel on
that ball to left field that ball was
smoked
third of the year is second in as many
games and there it goes out to left
[Applause]
a nice comfortable lead for the
right-hander peacock our alaska usa
federal credit union called the bullpen
should be unusual for matt bicock to
throw less than two innings
escobar high throw and he's able to get
the runner at second base as van meter
gets the foot down just ahead of dazzy
and that's on number one
let's try this once more short hop
escobar gonna get the added first
and that's two down
this is out to center haven smith still
backing up
onto the warning track and there it is
diamondbacks
when it's 7-2 they've taken the first
two games of this series
and they continue rolling along
diamondbacks now
two over 500 at 14 and 12 they have won
nine of their last 11.